BEFORE THE 2019-2020 PAUSE.
SO NOW THE OILERS NEARLY TWO BR
NUGENT-HOPKINS HOVERING CLOSE
BY.
WHISTLES ACROSS, NURSE A ALONGS
MAYBE A 3 ON 1.
MAX  AND 0
WHEN THEY SCORE FIRST AND
McDAVIDJARVI SCORES!
AND TAKES THE LEAD FOR THE FIRI
HAS TO COME FROM THE POINT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS FOR
HE WANTED ON THAT SHOT.
WHISTLED ACROSS
TALK ABOUT SNAPPING A PUCK
AROUND.
THAT PASS RIGHT THERERE SHOT AN
REBOUND, RYAN, FIRST GOAL SINCE
A PPED OFF THE GLASS AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE CALLED.
JENNERERHE
RESULTS.
>> McDAVID SNATCHES A CLEARING
EFFORT FROM MERZLIKINS A
OVECHKIN VORACEK.
WERENSKI.
CHINAKHOV, TRYING TO GO INSIDE.
AND OFF THE LEFT BABAcDAVID, CI
UP DOWN, FIVE HOLE. ON
HE W NURSE.
KASSIAN. DRAISAITL
KASSIAN!
REBOUND, S S BLUE JACKETS
WITH HIM.
AND HAS HAD THEUST PUCK TO THE
TRAFFIC.
I DON'T REALLY THINK ANY
PULJUJARVI SHOT OFF THE PASS.
AND
SILLINGER DRAWS IT BACK.  SHOUL
AND FOLLOW THE BOUNCING
SKINNER IN HIS LAST START FOR
BAKERSFIELD PITCTC COUNT.
REBOUND, SCORE!   TO GET
THAT TOOTY.
UNABLE
HAS TO FIGHT TO GET TO IT.
PUT IT IN RIGHT